foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored it
was a hundred days ago that Rishi sunak
stood on these very steps outside number
10 Downing Street and became Britain's
third prime minister in a year
he inherited a hell of a mess so how has
he done I'm about to go behind those
doors and ask him in his only interview
on this auspicious occasion
[Music]
good evening and welcome to a special
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored here
from number 10 Downing Street it was a
hundred days ago that Rishi sunak stood
on these steps and announced himself to
the country as our third prime minister
in less than a year he inherited a hell
of a mess let's be honest Liz truss had
driven us into an iceberg
the economy was tanking the pound was
collapsing we were a global laughing
stock Rishi sunak's challenge was to try
and get things back on some kind of even
Keel but he also had to deal with the
cost of living crisis that was almost
unprecedented with a war raging in
Ukraine
with his own side splitting two with
ex-prime ministers On Maneuvers with the
Royals and Chaos as well with a new
monarch all in all it added up to one
hell of a mess and one hell of a baptism
of fire so how has he got on well on his
100th day in office I spent nearly an
hour as the Prime Minister asking him a
lot of questions
time to put the Periscope up and unleash
a little torpedo to remind Boris who the
actual prime minister is what is sunac
is it what is the doctrine you have for
leadership of this country what is a
woman was your proposal romantic Ben
didn't he
you are a little romantic yes are also
going to win the league
fair and right is it should King Charles
invite Megan and Harry to the coronation
I had a feeling you might ask me that
Richie sunak's name and we all know he's
our prime minister but do we really feel
we know him as a man I'm not sure we do
so one of my challenges in the interview
was to try and peel back this slick
layer that he always seems to have and
find out who the actual person is behind
all that who is Rishi sunak where has he
come from what are his values what
drives him what does he want Britain to
be these are all big questions for our
prime minister in these turbulent times
and the answers matter
but first let's take a look back as to
how he got to become Prime Minister in
the first place it is clearly now the
will of the Parliamentary conservative
party that there should be a new leader
of that party and therefore a new prime
minister Liz we have to be honest we
have to be honest but borrowing your way
out of inflation isn't a plan it's a
fairy tale Liz truss is elected as the
leader of the conservative and Union as
well
I will deliver a bowl plan to cut taxes
and grow our economy the government was
saying this is great news the voting
confidence for markets and then down
down down I am a fighter and not a
quetter
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning Rishi sunak is therefore
elected as leader of the concept
thank you so here we go then pm and the
PM an exclusive interview on his
hundredth day in office let's see what
he has to say for himself
prime minister thank you very much for
inviting me into your your lair here the
number 10 kitchen very welcome Boris
Johnson repeatedly promised me an
interview at Downing Street and
eventually ran in to a fridge to hide
from me to avoid having to fulfill his
his pledge your fridge is over there can
you at least give me a guarantee in the
next
35 minutes you're not going to run into
that fridge I I can give you that
guarantee but though if you get hungry
halfway through we can read it for some
snacks
it's a hundred days today
two list trusses or ten lettuces we
worked out because the lettuce lasted 10
days which was longer than your
predecessor
was your first priority if you're on it
simply survival given the turmoil of
what had happened before
you know actually I I wasn't thinking
about politics when Liz resigned at all
I was uh I was with my kids having lunch
up up north at in t-side at TGI Fridays
and we were finishing off lunch and
about to head to take them bowling and I
had somewhat moved on after everything
that happened over the summer so my head
wasn't completely in that space if I'm
being completely honest and obviously
she resigned and
you don't have to think about what to do
and ultimately I strongly believe in
public service and felt out of a sense
of Duty more than anything else that I
should try and come and make a
difference given it was a pretty
challenging time had it crossed your
mind when you lost that leadership race
to just get out of politics because it's
a you know it's a brutal business you'd
had to go at running leadership it
hadn't worked had it gone through your
mind to just actually try something else
not not to leave politics and I'm very
devoted to my constituents at home in
North Yorkshire and Richmond
so I hadn't considered leaving politics
altogether but I had obviously assumed
that my career in Frontline politics had
come to an end we're talking for four
months ago yeah no that's right
my Fridays with your kids you're
thinking well I'll never work in a
cabinet again yeah that's what that's
what I was assuming and now you're in
number 10. yeah we're in your flare
you're the boss you're the Prime
Minister it's a little bit yeah it was a
look it was not what I was expecting I
knew when I resigned when I resigned as
Chancellor I said at the time like that
was probably I knew that would be the
last I resigned thinking and believing
that would probably then be the last
senior job I had in politics that's what
I thought I was doing and not to leave
politics all together but as you said I
didn't expect to be in in cabin or serve
in a position like this again um so yeah
it came the whole thing came as a pretty
big surprise but as I said the country
was in a difficult spot and you think I
mean and I thought I could make a
difference you said in in 2020 when
asked if you were after of a top job God
no definitely not seeing what the Prime
Minister has to deal with and then a
year later you run for that job
at a time in the economy is tanking the
party's cratering in the polls it was a
raging war in Europe the worst cost of
living crisis in a lifetime the remnants
of this terrible pandemic it's pretty
much the worst imaginable Hospital past
any incoming prime minister could ever
wish to receive which begs the question
what on Earth did you want to do this
for yeah well thanks for reminding me
first of all a long list and look you're
right and there's no point sugar coating
it it's not an easy situation and you
know I I also you know I do ask myself
the same question on on occasion I you
know I guess that's what I said before
it's a for me it's about Duty and
actually there's a concept in Hinduism
called Dharma which you know roughly
translates into duty and you know it's
that's how I was raised it was about
doing doing the things that were
expected of you and make trying to do
the right thing
and even though it was going to be a
nightmare job for all the reasons that
you outlined you know I felt that I
could make a difference and I was the
best person to make a difference at that
moment especially given the challenges
that people were facing and what they
were seeing with their mortgages and
that's that's ultimately why I put
myself forward to do it and knowing that
it would be difficult and challenging
but ultimately doing what I thought was
my duty in that situation because I
believe deeply in service and and
thought I could make a difference to the
country when I interviewed Tony Blair
when he was prime minister here at
Downing Street he had a singing fish on
the wall called Billy bash bass I think
it was uh that used to sing if you
pressed a button Don't Worry Be Happy
do you have anything like that and what
is your Mantra now I uh I have my wife
but she doesn't sing Don't Worry Be
Happy
um and I know and we do like Bob Marley
but
um no look what's the right Mantra right
now for the public so many people yeah
are suffering so many people are
worrying what is your message to them
it's have hope have hope because I can
make it better and I will make it better
and that's what I said that's what I'm
working day and night to do that's why I
put myself forward for this and that's
why at the beginning of the year I set
out for the country the five things I
wanted to do for them which are quite
straightforward in in one sense the
problem you have I've seen the five
pledges yeah discuss those there's a new
poll out today you gov times times radio
that says pretty much on almost every
metric the three quarters of the public
do not think you're delivering on any of
the things you're now pledging to fix
three quarters don't think you're going
to be prime minister after the next
election these are you know pretty heavy
stats against you you haven't got that
much time to turn this around you've got
about 500 days or so maximum can you do
it have you got enough time to implement
these changes and actually see change be
affected yes I I wholeheartedly believe
that and I'm giving absolutely
everything I've got and of course people
might not feel that today and for all
the reasons that you you set out earlier
the situation is tough but I want people
to have confidence that it will get
better so if you you know go through
those things I said half inflation yes I
believe by the end of the year we can
have inflation grow the economy yes I do
believe over the course of this year
we'll get the economy growing again
reduce debt we've already made some
difficult decisions to to ensure that
that happens but we've got to stick to
the path and then cutting waiting lists
I was just in hospital earlier this week
talking about our plans to bring down
waiting times in the NHS which I know we
can deliver on we're working with the
NHS to do that and stopping the boats
and tackling illegal migration that's
probably the trickiest of all of them
but again it's something that I care
very deeply about and and I by the end
of the year when hopefully we come back
and do this again and you can give me my
report card on those five things I I am
confident that we will have delivered on
them in the country at that point will
be able to say hang on this guy
said he was going to do these things and
he's done them and that's what I want to
be judged by because I think politicians
say lots of things and the country's
probably quite frankly sick and tired of
it right for what they want is someone
to just do the things that they say and
that's what I'm going to do political
words are cheap right I mean anyone can
sit as prime minister and say to me I'm
going to fix everything the proof will
be literally in the pudding right and I
will set you up on that I will come back
yeah because people want to see actual
delivery they do I believe that and
that's why you know actually I get you
talk about those five things and all
that polling other people say oh gosh
that's not ambitious enough at all and
where's the Grand Vision and all the
rest of it and what I'd say to them is
these are the things that matter most to
the country you have a Doctrine I mean
people are struggling to see what your
what is sunakism what is the doctrine
you have for leadership of this country
well first of all it's about making sure
that people can feel proud of the UK
proud of our country and that they have
peace of mind that things are going to
be better for their children and
grandchildren now that's what I'm driven
to deliver and right now what does that
mean it means delivering on those five
things because that's how we're going to
do that that's how we're going to make
sure people do have peace of mind that
things will be better for their children
for their grandchildren that is how we
will make sure people feel proud of our
country and that's why those five things
are the most important things to focus
on how would you assess your first
hundred days
yeah I'm
well as you said I came in and it was a
challenging situation but I'm proud of
what we've achieved I'm proud and how do
you achieve if you if you look at some
of the things that we've done in that
relatively short space of time first and
most importantly is taking action to
stabilize the economy and you you
mentioned it earlier about the situation
that the country faced in the Autumn
last year and it was it was pretty Stark
right people were absolutely terrified
about what was going to happen to their
mortgages what was going on and we came
in I came in and we took pretty decisive
action in the Autumn statement last year
to put in place an economic plan that
brought borrowing into under control
calmed the markets down made sure that
the increase in interest rates is is
going to be far less than people had
feared and that's going to make an
enormous difference to millions of
people's lives
more extraordinary Revelations from our
prime minister is Rwanda ever going to
happen
[Music]
oh fantastic hello how are you this is
it I'm so excited the conservative party
can certainly win the next election can
we yes sir Crasher Rooney's snooze Fest
kissed armor
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister he is an else up front
making the case you're making the case
here now he's invisible tune in Friday
night with Nadine 8pm
[Music]
thank you
we have just this extraordinary
compulsion to kill this woman yes sir by
looking at somebody who did do that in
which case you're one of the worst
people I've ever met in my life I don't
believe you I think you did kill these
women yes they need is it justice
is he the purest personification of a
psychopath do you think there is
something wrong with it oh yeah I'm
innocent
[Music]
thank you
all right fantastic hello how are you
this is it I'm so excited the
conservative party can certainly win the
next match can we yes so Crasher
Rooney's snooze Fest kissed armor
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister he isn't out at the front
making the case you're making the case
here now he's invisible tune in for
Friday night with Nadine 8pm
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to this special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored the number 10
Downing Street but many people would say
all right yes the pound dollar rate for
example is back up to a much higher
level and so on there's Merit to what
you've just said but they would say for
example your pledge about the boats the
small boats coming over they'd say not
only if you're not delivered this
situation just seems to be getting worse
all the time or one of the key things
that brexit was supposed to be getting
control of our borders it seems to be
completely out of control what are you
actually going to do yeah about that for
example yeah so let's we'll take a step
back first of all why is that why is
that issue important to me because it is
and it's a thing I spent an enormous
amount of time on it because ultimately
for me it comes down to fairness and
fairness really matters to me and I
don't think the current situation is
fair right people coming here illegally
it's not fair on those who are working
hard paying taxes relying on public
services it's not fair on those who
migrate here legally and follow all the
rules and it's actually not fair on
those who desperately need our help from
around the world and we're not in a
position to be able to help them because
of what's happening so for all those
reasons we need to fix this and for me
you know what what I hear when someone
says well you know if someone comes here
and claims Asylum illegally they can't
be illegal they claim an asylum I hear
that so that's wrong right when I hear
that someone has paid thousands of
pounds to come here and exploit our
world-leading modern slavery laws that's
wrong or when I hear that someone's
trying to you know game the system
whether it's human rights or exploit our
compassion and frustrate their removal
to a safe place like Albania or Rwanda
that's wrong so we have to fix all those
things the system that we need the
system that I want to introduce is one
whereby if you come here illegally you
should be swiftly detained and then in a
matter of days or weeks we will hear
your claim not months and years and then
we will safely remove you somewhere else
and if we do that that's how we'll break
the cycle because if all these Smugglers
if they see that that happens I
understand but I've heard I have heard
this a lot
so look in the first hundred days what
have we done what have I done a I've got
a new deal with France which is
increasing the amount of patrols that
are happening on French beaches which is
making a difference already secondly
I've got a brand new deal with Albania
Albania accounted for a 30 of all the
illegal immigrants of course that's
ridiculous but I've worked with the
albanians to put in place a new deal
which means for people coming from
Albania illegally we will be able to
remove them safely back to Albania and
that is already happening we're putting
illegal migrants from Albania back on
flight and that will ratchet up over the
year and that's tangible Improvement in
the situation that deal is a new deal
and then we're wholesale changing how
our Asylum system works in the UK to
make sure that we process things far
quicker and more efficiently we've got
more enforcement of people who are
working illegally but the key thing we
need to do is introduce new laws and
very soon we'll be introducing new laws
into Parliament which deliver the system
that I explained the system which says
if you come here illegally you're not
really going to be able to stay here
give me the simple explanation of what
this new law will look like so what that
law will say is if you come here
illegally for an illegal migrant here
then you will not be able to stay here
and in fact we will be able to detain
you and then we will hear your claim in
a matter of days or weeks not months or
years and we will have the ability in
the vast majority of cases to send you
to an alternative safe country be that
be where you've come from if it's safe
like Albania or indeed Rwanda that is
the system is Rwanda ever going to
happen yes I mean we're working our way
through the courts with that and of
course they're going to be people who
try and frustrate this but that is a
system that I think the vast majority of
people watching will say that sounds
reasonable how do you couple it with
Humanity how do you work out who are
genuine Asylum Seekers who do who
actually want our help because they're
desperate perhaps from a war-torn
country from a war that we were involved
in so there's a couple of things a
you're absolutely right but that that is
the bit that we have to get right
because we're always going to be a
compassionate country it's something
that we're all very proud of and that's
why drafting the law is is not
straightforward and we're taking the
time to get it absolutely right so that
we can capture those genuine cases which
of course we want to but the other thing
is this as we've demonstrated over the
past year or two when we need to open up
our hearts and our homes in this country
to those fleeing persecution whether
it's at Afghanistan Syria Hong Kong
Ukraine we do and that's what being
British is all about but it needs to be
done on our terms so what I think
actually is once we've got a grip of
this system and we've largely stopped
the flow of illegal migrants we can have
a much more sensible conversation as a
country in saying well who do we want to
take from where and how many what's our
ability to to help these people and
actually have that conversation
proactively and work with the Red Cross
and the UN and others to do that but
first we've got to stop the illegal
migration have you told your Home
Secretary to dial down her rhetoric
which many people think has been overly
inflammatory and degrading in some cases
about migrants well I think look people
are frustrated with this situation I'm
frustrated with this situation but the
right way to deal with it is to do the
things that I'm saying and that's
required some hard work to get but on
language specifically well on language
look we should always remember that
we're a compassionate country right and
we've demonstrated that as I said with
Hong Kong Hong Kong Afghanistan Syria
Ukraine we're a compassionate country
can you remind me your Home Secretary
she believes that everyone believes that
in the government and we've demonstrated
that as a country those are our values
but we're not a soft touch right we're
not a soft touch we believe in playing
by the rules We Believe In fairness as
well that is also equally British and we
need a system that delivers that and
that's the bit that we're going to fix
[Music]
oh fantastic hello how are you this is
it I'm so excited the conservative party
can certainly win the next election can
we yes sir Crasher Rooney's snooze Fest
kissed armor
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister he isn't out up front
making the case you're making the case
here now he's invisible tune in Friday
night with Nadine 8pm
[Music]
thank you foreign
you have just this extraordinary
compulsion to kill this woman yes sir by
looking at somebody who did do that in
which case you're one of the worst
people I've ever met in my life I don't
believe you I think you did kill these
women yes they need is it justice
purist personification of a psychopath
do you think there is something wrong
with you oh yeah Minnesota
[Music]
thank you
all right fantastic hello how are you
this is it I'm so excited the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election yes sir Crasher Rooney's
snooze Fest kissed armor
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister he isn't out up front
making the case you're making the case
here now he's invisible tune in Friday
night with Nadine 8pm
[Music]
this is talk TV
and talk about fairness
a lot of strikes going on at the moment
you're being very Resolute as things
stand and standing up to the unions not
proving very popular to the public again
three-quarters think the unions have got
the edge in this at the moment
I want to talk specifically about nurses
mainly because your father was an NHS GP
your mother ran the Family Pharmacy
you're a person who grew up
around the health system around Health
Care it must burn in your soul
nurses we were told to go out and
applaud every Thursday in the pandemic
many of them died in the pandemic
risking their life to save people's
lives they to me should be made an
exception and yet you barely negotiated
with the nursing unions do you not feel
this Duty that you talked about to
actually take care of nurses and say
actually we do have to make some
exceptions and at top of my list my
priority is going to be nurses and give
them a proper pay rise
you know you're you're right nurses
should be an exception and that's
because they do an incredible job for
all of us and they demonstrated that
during the pandemic and I'm really
grateful to them for that and you're
right I grew up in an NHS family so this
does burn deeply inside of me because I
know how important great health care is
for people and including my own family
and we did treat them as an exception
you know people forget that actually
during during covid when I was
Chancellor we instituted a public sector
pay for ease because actually wages for
most people were were going down and
what we decided in that context given
everything going on that there should be
a pay freeze across the entire public
sector so everyone working in the public
sector didn't see their wages rise
during covert given the economic
situation but you know what there was
one exception to all of that it was
people working in the NH yeah but it was
nursing I know but it's right it's not
very completely dwarfed as you know by
inflation but hang on a bit your
principle though that yeah that we
should treat is one that I agree with
and it's one that I've actually
delivered when I was Chancellor
and then when we're talking about this
and I'm really glad actually that to
have an opportunity to talk about it now
look it's not always easy in this job
because I'm focused on doing what I
believe is right for the country and in
the long term and often that means doing
things that maybe not always popular and
this is a good example of that but let
me explain why we're doing what we're
doing and why I think it's important
look I would love right I would love to
give the nurses a massive pay rise who
wouldn't certainly would make my life
easier wouldn't it right of course I
would love to do that if I could give
them on them so why is that tough right
why is it tough it's it's about choices
so right now there's a record amount of
money going into the NHS record amount
and in spite of those difficult
decisions that we had to make to
stabilize the economy which with the
right decisions we found more money for
the NHS and social care because I
believe that was the right thing to do
so right now money going to the NHS
biggest it's never been but we have to
put that in lots of different places we
need to hire more doctors more nurses we
need more scanning equipment so we can
detect cancer we need more ambulances I
understand but to do that to recruit
people you've got to make them think
there's an environment that's worth
working in that they're going to be
actually treated in the way that we
treated them in the pandemic with all
our applauding I mean one specific thing
I really got my goat about the nurses is
in the pandemic after a campaign which I
led actually
car park charges were removed from all
hospitals for nurses right because they
were paying up to a thousand pounds each
a year to park their car outside a place
they were going in to save lives it
seemed to be Preposterous in Scotland
and Wales they don't have that charge
but now the pandemic's over that's come
back and they're now facing charges
again of a thousand pounds a year you
can't think that's right surely the
nurses in England have to pay a thousand
pounds a year for the privilege of
parking outside a hospital to save lives
so actually what we've done is put in
place support for trust to be able to
support their stuff why don't you just
say enough well and just continue what
happened on the pandemic yeah well
because there's other things that we've
done for nurses as well because you're
right it's not just about Payless you
know that's not fair well there's other
ways that we can demonstrate on that
point though it's not fair is it well
everyone watching this show will get to
work in lots of different ways I know
right and but not many are actually
going to actually save lives and they're
paying a thousand pounds on average
for the pleasure of parking outside a
hospital it's ridiculous yeah and that's
why we put measures in place actually
and more funding to ease the burden of
hospital car parking lot not just on
employees but also on patients but
probably there on a regular basis that's
actually what's happened is a lot of
these trusts have actually put the
prices up they're now paying more than
nursing staff than they were before the
pandemic again I simply say dude that's
not fair is it it's not right well here
are some of the other things we're doing
right because again don't change your
subject on that it's not fair and right
is it well let me tell you some of the
other things we're doing I know you
don't think it is well look of course
what I would I love it if people have to
pay less to get to work of course I
would right and of course I'd love that
for everybody why are nurses in Scotland
and Wales valued more
they also pay higher taxes a typical
nurse in Scotland
right will you at least look at that of
course I'm happy to look at that right
of course I think you should I think
it's a big deal for a lot of users but
it's really important so look here are
some of the other things that we've done
and then I want to get on to the point
on pay but so you're right because
there's lots of other ways we can value
people we've reinstituted nurses
bursaries so if you're training to be a
nurse 5 000 pounds a year bursary that's
not available for people studying other
subjects that's because we care about
nurses in particular you ask they should
be treated differently they are that's
very generous something else the union
asked us for a year before last was when
nurses qualify we want to keep
supporting because they want to keep
learning new skills so they can help
more patients we said great we'll
support that thousand pounds of a
trading budget for every newly quality
but here's the problem so let's get on
to pay though so I just want to say
here's what you're not mentioning in
this context which is Raging inflation
means that all this stuff has been
completely dwarfed so you know as well
as I do that nurses are actually out of
pocket despite all this they're
massively out of pocket because of
inflation and I think that if with
countries told to go out and applaud
these people every Thursday we're
risking their lives in a pandemic and
our reward is to kick him in the teeth
the moment it's over I don't think it's
fair so I don't think that's a fair
characterization of it I don't think
that's a fair characterization of it at
all right but look this is really
important so give me a second to explain
give me a second to explain so nurses
are getting a pay rise they're getting a
pay rise of about five percent and much
higher actually for lower paid nurses so
that is happening right and and it goes
back to the question of there are all
these other things that we need to do in
the NHS as well we need more nurses we
need more answers we need more scanners
no no but this is the other thing is
about so look I don't think anyone
watching this show would you as well
would say okay great we need to put up
everyone's taxes to pay for that because
money has to come from somewhere doesn't
it right I don't think that's what
everyone is saying the other thing is
you're right the thing that is making
life difficult for nurses and for
everyone else is and inflation it's the
bills that are going up and up and up
we've got to tackle inflation that's why
it's the first Wi-Fi priorities and
unfortunately in a situation where
you've got high inflation if lots and
lots of people get very large pay
settlements it makes the inflation
problem worse and last longer and that
is not going to help anybody including
nurses and that's why even if it's not
popular it's the right thing for other
countries you pledge to clean up British
politics and rebuild trust through
integrity and accountability but your
point is swella bravaman as Homer
secretary six days after she quit over
security breaches appointed Gavin
Williamson to your cabinet despite him
being fired twice before by your
predecessors then you had to get rid of
him almost immediately over a bullying
scandal you just have to fire your party
chairman Nadeem zahawi over a tax
Scandal you know Deputy Prime Minister
Dominic Robb is facing Serious Mass
bullying allegations
that's just in four months prime
minister
people are saying what is going on here
how does this live up to trust through
integrity and accountability it just
looks like more of the same
well actually people can judge me on how
I've dealt with these situations as
they've Arisen right and in most cases
that you you mentioned you're talking
about things that happened day before I
was prime minister but as they've Arisen
on my watch I've actually worked in a
way that I believe to be professional in
a way that I believe does restore
Integrity back into the process are you
comfortable about Dominic Robb staying
in his job at the moment and not being
suspended pending resolution of this
investigation yes because I believe in
due process I believe people should have
a fair hearing and that's why we have an
independent advisor and I think as
people saw at the weekend that
independent advisor who I'd asked to
look into the Nadine zahawi situation
looked at it quickly didn't put any
punches when he wrote his Rapport and
immediately after I received that report
I acted decisively to remove Nadeem
sahawi from government because there had
been a serious breach in the ministerial
he had to go over tax
a lot of people have asked questions
about your wealth you know that you're a
very wealthy man I don't hold that
against you being very successful in
business
you've said that you'll release your tax
returns but we haven't seen them yet
when are you going to do that how far
back are you going to go would it not be
if you're going to be transparent about
this go back to when you first became an
MP and say right here you are here's
eight years of my tax returns so I I
will be transparent they will go back
they generally there's a precedent for
these things so from one word assume for
all MPS we don't tend to do that this is
something that we restrict but you want
to be transparent than Prime Ministers
or chancellors or all theirs in the past
they will be published shortly the tax
debt as you know the tax filing deadline
was just a few days ago so that's why so
we do the tax filing deadlines just
passed so they're just being prepared
and they will be released can you answer
one specific about it a lot of people
have been suggesting that you may have
benefited some way financially from
pharmaceutical companies during the
pandemic either through a blind trust or
otherwise can you clear that up have you
made any personal financial gain from
pharmaceutical companies and in
particular from moderna who of course
made a lot of money from the vaccine so
all my disclosures are done through the
cabinet office and what you'll see if
you read the the statement that they put
out is that my investments are in what's
called a blind management Arrangement so
I don't actually have any knowledge of
what is in there and that's how that
works so you could have made I I I'm not
the whole point about something that's
truly blind is that it's blind from me
do you think it's right that a prime
minister should have blind trust I I
think that's better than them having
control over them clearly that is the
long established process for how these
things work because the point is if
they're blind I'm not able to direct or
control what's going on we will see the
returns of it the tax returns yes you
will see them soon yeah I committed to
doing that and I and they will be done
but you know we just finished the tax
filing deadline at the end of January so
they just need to be then prepared and
they'll be released soon
[Music]
oh fantastic hello how are you this is
it I'm so excited the conservative party
can certainly win the next election can
we yes sir Crasher Rooney's snooze Fest
kirst armor
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister he isn't out up front
making the case you're making the case
here now he's invisible tune in for
Friday night with Nadine 8pm
[Music]
you have just this extraordinary
compulsion to kill this woman yes sir by
looking at somebody who did do that in
which case you're one of the worst
people I've ever met in my life I don't
believe you I think you did kill these
women yes they need is it justice
is he the purest personification of a
psychopath get in there is something
wrong with it uh yeah I'm innocent
[Music]
foreign
how are you this is it I'm so excited
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes sir Crasher
Rooney's snooze Fest kissed armor
can't we this is like some kind of
submarine prime minister he is an out at
the front making the case you're making
the case here now he's invisible tune in
for Friday night with Nadine 8pm
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you're watching a
special edition of Piers Morgan
uncensored from number 10 down history
Ukraine Boris Johnson one of your two
recent predecessors has been on
maneuvers around the world meeting
President zielinski meeting Senate
leaders in America almost acting like
he's still prime minister uh Nadine
Doris has interviewed for talk TV for
tomorrow night in which she says that
you're a submarine prime minister is it
time to put the Periscope up and unleash
a little torpedo to remind Boris who the
actual prime minister is now look it's
you know it's great that we've got
former Prime Ministers and I speak to
you know all our former leaders actually
should he be doing what he's doing I
think all of our leaders have a way of
continuing to contribute to public life
and that's that's a good thing that's
not a bad thing actually they've got
experience that they want to share you
have no problem with what borrowers are
doing oh gosh I've like as I say look
we've got a long list of previous Prime
Ministers and the fact that they still
want to continue he's all over life he's
all over American television so we need
to send Jets to Ukraine so on on Ukraine
in particular actually when you talk
about what else we've done in 100 days
that's one of the other things I'm proud
that I've been here people to achieve
and that is to shift our strategy on
Ukraine as prime minister to a more
proactive strategy will you send Jets
and so look we are always talking to the
ukrainians about the right support they
want Jets Boris Johnson says
defense minister says he's not going to
rule it out you're the Prime Minister
it's going to be your call yes so should
we send Jeff so the issue is what is the
support that we can provide that we
think will make the most difference and
that's why a decision I took as prime
minister was to be one of the first
countries in the world to provide heavy
tanks to Ukraine and that we were Then
followed by other countries specifically
about Jets yes but I said we are always
you don't know about art no we're always
in a dialogue with our Ukrainian friends
about what the right way to support them
is the thing to bear in mind with jets
there remember these are incredibly
sophisticated uh pieces of equipment
that require months if not years for
people to be trained on but you don't
but you don't rule anything out on our
our desire and goal is for Ukraine to
win this conference and to give them
what they need and we want to make sure
that it's all about giving them
necessarily just giving them what they
need we need to make sure that they can
use what they are given and that's
actually with with tanks people saying
well why am I not seeing them tomorrow
it's because we also need to make sure
that they're trained to use the tags and
that work is ongoing at the moment so
it's not just the equipment it's also
the capabilities and the training that
come alongside that okay together with a
plan with our allies it will ensure that
they can be Victorious and that's the
strategy that I've shifted as prime
minister and it's something I'm proud
we've done in 100 days and I know
something that president zielinski and
the ukrainians are deeply grateful to us
for okay we share a love of cricket
and I would say I don't mean this is an
insult prime minister but when it comes
to your wife you're you're batting above
your average would you agree yes 100 uh
no you said in the times and I wasn't
sure where this interview got into
trouble but you said that you're tidy
she's messy yes you're organized she's
not yeah your tea total she likes a
drink was it Opposites Attract uh well
that you'd have to ask her
um but yes I definitely am batting above
my average and I did get in a lot of
trouble for that interview so I should
just uh reassert that I I did those
things were taken I think a little bit
in a more extreme way than I meant then
are you apparently you like rom-coms I
do yes I love actually like anything all
that kind of thing so you're a romantic
guy uh yeah I'd I'd like to think so
you're probably better off to ask her
rather than was your was your proposal
romantic I I think so she said yes so it
had the design can we have a bit of uh
we yes we got engaged in a place called
Half Moon Bay and it was a it was a
place that when we were students ago we
met when we were studying together in
the states and we used to walk in this
area and look up at this nice fancy
hotel that we never could stay in and
then I surprised her and we did go and
stay there but before that we went for a
walk along the cliffs and we were alone
and that's why I proposed Ben didn't he
of course really yes so you are a little
romantic yes well what does love mean to
you
love what does love mean well I mean it
I mean there's there's lots of different
aspects to it and the the bit that is
the bit that I'm probably most uh
focused on at the moment and the bit
that means the most to me at the moment
is the support that she gives me doing
this job and well they say behind every
great man is a as a greater woman yeah
and then in my case that is definitely
true and it has been particularly true
over the past couple of months in the
past couple of years I wouldn't be able
to do this job without her her love and
support as you said you said what's your
Mantra or how did your what's my
equivalent of the singing fish uh doing
Bob Marley it's after that right and
that's that's what I get every day that
gives me the extra support to keep going
when things are tough that comes from
her so you were very you were very old
at the moment you were very supportive
of women in the comments yesterday in
relation to Rosie Duffield the problem
she said with Kirsten the world's most
controversial question bizarrely has
become what is a woman
we know that Nicholas sturgeon can't
answer that we know Kia starmer can't
answer that you're the British prime
minister what is a woman yeah I of
course I know a woman who adult human
female and what you're actually now
asking when you ask that question is I I
think you know what's my Approach in
view about how we as a society grapple
with a situation where people are
questioning and wanting to change their
gender there we just have this shocking
case in Scotland where a male rapist who
raped two women before he comes to trial
suddenly decides to transition to be
supposedly a woman he gets convicted as
a woman and then gets sent first of all
to a woman's prison where there will be
other women for him to attack and his
ex-wife says well this is ridiculous
he's just doing this because he's
monster soft option of being in a
women's prison he's now been sent back
to a male prison and therefore we have
to assume is now being categorized as
male but this shows the problem of
Limitless gender self-identity this is
where it takes us I completely agree it
absolutely does show some of the
challenges with this I mean look first
of all we we must and should have
enormous compassion and tolerance and
understanding for those who are
questioning their gender and identity
and wanting to change and we will always
be supportive of that of course we will
and it's right to be compassionate about
that that's who we are as a people but
we have to recognize the challenges that
that poses particularly for women's
safety as we've just when you see indeed
that's why biological sex really matters
in yeah I mean it to me it's it's
immutable that's what it is it's
biological sex when you see what's
happening in sport where you see trans
women athletes demolishing women female
athletes what do you feel about that
well I think that doesn't strike most
people as being fair right so and so
that's why when it comes to these
questions biological sex matters now
that you know we can and will have
compassion and tolerance and
understanding for everyone body who is
thinking about transitioning and
changing their identity and gender but
you know for me when it comes to whether
it's sex whether it's women's spaces
whether it's prisons biological sex
really matters and actually we saw that
recently with what's going on in
Scotland and that's why I took again you
say what else have you done in 100 days
and what's bold you know we took action
that I thought you were completely right
because you know the the bill that was
passed in Scotland I think has real
implications for the how we think about
these issues on a uk-wide basis and the
interaction between these things I think
on this you're completely right I'm glad
I'm glad you've said what a woman is
because a lot of people were thinking
why can't we say one I mean yes and look
I I'm married to one I have two
daughters and it's really important that
they grow up in a society way where
their needs are are respected whether
it's you know how they want to be
treated when they're in changing rooms
or sports but also their safety and the
other thing I've spoken about is you
know women walking around in the
evenings should and deserve to feel safe
yes and and they should be and deserve
to feel safe and we haven't done a good
enough job of that in the past and we're
working really hard to improve things
but it's something that I hope I can
achieve as prime minister that women do
feel that because that's what we all owe
them what's the biggest frustration for
you about how people view you a lot of
people think you're a better than nerd
you know you're a Goldman Sachs guy I've
been higher flyer all your life you're a
bit of a geek I don't think you are from
what I've been told by people who know
you well you know apparently you you rap
to i-sized Baby by Vanilla rice is that
true that that is true yes we will not
do that now and you keep Star Wars
lightsabers I I'm a big Star Wars fan do
you keep them in down his room uh I
don't know if we have one actually down
in the kids room we might but yes I'm a
big starter feelers with you uh well I
hope the Force is with me yeah you need
it what is the voice what is the force
I hate it oh God we haven't got time for
that in this interview we'll have a
whole separate Star Wars interview have
you not watched any songs I don't know
okay fine well when we're watching some
football I think when we're watching our
thoughts together I think Ryan men
running around waving lightsabers is
ridiculous well I I have I have children
so I get permission to play Star Wars
Lego and lightsabers are you still the
coke addict uh yes yeah but down one a
week one a week one a week so I mean I'm
really proper coat not a diet one and I
have this special thing for a particular
type of coke which is in the fridge
somewhere and you're a panason guy I am
I am too but you you go with Cody right
I do I'm an Olivia oh really yeah okay
I'll try that
all right Cody's good that's another way
you get cheers you up gets you going
I've got to write myself no you ask it
actually about that about your character
yeah
and I was I mean as you said it I was
reflecting on it look what does that
mean you know to me what like that means
somebody who is getting up early who's
working hard who's on top of things
who's trying to actually solve problems
and be diligent about that and throw
themselves at it and give absolutely
everything that they've got day and
night to try and do it then sure that is
who I am I'm not going to run away from
that and I quite frankly I think that's
what the Prime Minister should be yeah I
think that's what the country deserves
and we've got some challenges and we're
not going to solve them unless the
person doing this job is like that in my
view so I have one concern about this
you don't drink you just hate the taste
of alcohol right yes you've never smoked
no never taken drugs
your stinking Ridge
right
well it's a matter of degree I think
most people would consider that I am I'm
financially fortunate yes and you've got
a degree from a U.S University
and a British one as well right but my
point about the first five things I said
is that the only other world leader I've
interviewed who ticked all those same
boxes was Donald Trump
should we be concerned
is this a trait that we should be
worried about gosh I uh I think of all
the people people would have compared me
to that is not one that I would have
imagined um but look look on on those
things I guess you need to say whatever
what are people are more frustrated and
all the rest of it
I think what people need to understand
is what my values are I think that's the
most important what are they and that's
how I was brought up right and I was
brought up by you know parents who
emigrated to this country and they came
with an immigrant mindset whereby what
they were focused on was working as
humanly hard as possible and sacrificing
everything so that their kids could have
a better future and that we could fit in
and integrate into British life well and
that's what I was raised I was raised to
work incredibly hard to do the right
thing to the god of people who are less
fortunate than yourselves because that's
what my parents were doing and those are
the values that I bring to this job now
yes am I financially lucky today I am
yeah I'm I'm that is as a result of all
this I mean by most most people would
consider that I am very is it I mean in
the spirit of transparency can you give
us are you a billionaire no I'm not
going to get into that no but the point
that what does does that what matters
about that is is not right how much is
in my bank account what matters and my
values and what matters are the actions
I take for the country and you know what
I have the same bank account when I was
Chancellor so when I stood up in that
first press conference where no one knew
who I was and I talked about what we
were going to do and I talked about
furlough right no one asked me then oh
how much money is in your bank account
right no one cared right so if it didn't
matter then it shouldn't matter now well
the first tax cut I ever did as
Chancellor was a tax cut for the lowest
paid it was those on Universal Credit
because I wanted to make it easier for
people who were moving off welfare and
wanted to move into a job I wanted them
to be able to keep more of their money
because I thought that was a really good
thing I believe really strongly in hard
work I think hard work is something that
we should reward how much is a pint of
milk 90p but you know what oh that's
good do you know what that when people
ask me that question you know what I
instinctly think of I think of the price
of milk that my farmers get because I
represent a very rural consistency in
North Yorkshire my neighbor is a Dairy
Farmer and when I first became an MP the
dairy industry was in a really tough way
you used to get farmers in my patch they
were getting paid 20 pence a liter
wholesale for their milk and right now
they were gonna get a record high it's
about 50 pence a liter so I don't get
too many complaints from my Dairy
Farmers in Yorkshire about milk prices
so that's what I think of and that's the
other thing that made a big impact on me
that's a big impact in my life was being
a member of parliament for a an amazing
part of the country it changed who I am
it's rural it's in the north it's where
we've made a home and people have
welcomed us and you know again I bring
those values to this job too
I would have been with three yes or no's
right right and then that's it then
you're out of this right first one
should the King Charles invite Megan and
Harry to the coronation you're going to
be there
I had a feeling you might ask me that so
look you you know you know I can't talk
about the royal family but what I can
say is one of the great privileges of
this job is spending time with the
Monarch and also championing what is an
amazing British institution should
people who came in the world should
people who keep trashing the royal
family monarchy just shut up look I I
said it's one of the proudest parts of
my job is to go around the world and
champion and celebrate British
institutions like the Royals Australians
have just taken all the rules off their
stamps yeah but you know what there's an
enormous amount of affection for the
royal family everywhere I go around the
world and they do an incredible Job King
Charles does an incredible job we're
lucky to have him the coronation is
going to be superb and we're going to
have a great time and you don't mind if
you're next to Megan and arrow I again
what I'm focused on to make sure we have
a great time as a country and that is
one confidence are we going to win the
ashes England yes are also going to win
the league yes so southampton's going to
get relegated no no
definitely not well actually if you
could spare off the points when we play
you that would be uh that would be okay
actually that's one of this one actually
you say where do you get your motivation
from so growing up and being a
Southampton fan in the 90s as my
formative teenage years we stayed up
most seasons on the last game of the
season one time on goal difference which
we call the Great Escape so I'm quite
comfortable with things being tough but
you know what in the end you can put it
out of the bag and that's a little bit
like this job at the moment things are
tough but I'm confident that they'll get
better and we'll be successful you've
got one of the toughest jobs I can
imagine I've interviewed many British
prime ministers over the years this is a
really tough job you're in but I like
the ambition you have and I like the
fact you're prepared for me to come back
at the end of the year and see how you
get on and be judged on performance
because I think what the British public
want right now is action and results and
less of the chat even though we've just
had a good chat we're having a good chat
we didn't need to read the free which is
a good thing and you haven't run into it
and I haven't run into it and we will go
celebrate with a Coke afterwards but
it's been great to spend some time with
you and you know I agree with you I
think that is what the country wants and
my job is to deliver for them and if I
don't do it then fair enough right then
I don't I don't deserve to have people
support me but I'm confident I can
deliver for people and at the end of the
year we can go through that checklist
and we can sit and say what have you
done and I look forward to that
conversation I'm gonna stop wish you all
the best I want you to succeed thank you
I think most people would like you to
succeed we've got enough chaos enough
failings we need this country back on
his feet and I hope you are successful
well I appreciate that and I know you'll
keep holding to me account for doing it
that you can absolutely rest assured now
go and sort the parking out for the
nurse right I'm on it good to see you
take care
so that's it my exclusive interview with
prime minister Rishi suneck on the 100th
day of his Premiership or as I put it at
the start of the interview two Liz
trusses already
I don't know what you thought of him but
I felt he was more candid and open in
that interview than I've ever seen him
before I also think that he means it
when he says he's determined to fix our
problems the big question remains can he
well the clock is ticking to the next
election if he doesn't the electorate
will be unforgiving but if he does well
it may not be over yet
that's it from Piers Morgan I'm censored
from Downing Street tonight remember
wherever you are even if you're the
Prime Minister Keep It Uncensored
[Music]
oh fantastic hello how are you this is
it I'm so excited the conservative party
can certainly win the next election can
we yes sir Crasher Rooney's snooze Fest
kissed armor
submarine prime minister he isn't out at
the front making the case you're making
the case here now he's invisible tune in
Friday night with Nadine 8pm
[Music]
foreign
to kill this woman yes sir by looking at
somebody who did do that in which case
you're one of the worst people I've ever
met in my life I don't believe you I
think you did kill these women because
they need is it justice you did kill
them didn't you is he the purest